my films represent innocent people who
have been murdered um
i make documentaries uh documentaries
are meant to inform educate and raise
awareness
for change for movements so um
thank god i was able to put 20 films on
amazon prime
that definitely increases the exposure
and i've been at it for 10 years i've
made 33 movies
if someone told me 10 years ago that i'd
be up to 33 movies by 2020
i would probably tell them i have a
better chance becoming pregnant
so this is a very um it's a very
grueling career
it's a grind um you just have to uh
work your tail off and i feel fortunate
that i'm sitting here
able to show my movies as an independent
filmmaker
in mainstream movie theaters especially
during a tough time of pandemic
the theaters are adhering to strict
social distancing guidelines
so um me personally i think it is
safe to go you just have to use common
sense
915 hunting hispanics will open this
friday at the boulevard mall
in las vegas the galaxy theaters
and the movie theaters only open on
weekends
so people would have to go on the
weekend to see the film friday saturday
sunday
it's going to be showing one time during
the day
the movie is a very serious look and a
close-up look at the
el paso walmart mass shooting this was
the ultimate hate crime
uh by a racist who drove 10 hours from
dallas to el paso
because he hated mexican people this was
the
ultimate ultimate racist here
it's a conversation most people don't
want to have racism
and i encourage difficult conversations
i think that leads to change
i think there's nothing wrong with that
i think we have to be honest about
everything not try to
sweep things under the rug not try to
run from things
racism is a huge problem today uh it's
unfortunate
people wake up bitter nasty uh
negative and the rate a lot of them
that are racist it's unfortunate because
you live once why be that way
so this country needs change and i think
we saw it big time this year when
we saw a policeman's knee on a person's
neck
that just kind of broke the year wide
open in terms of separation and divide
the george floyd incident when i see blm
yeah that's significant black lives
matter but sometimes i think a brown
lives matter
in this case mexican people were
targeted they were hunted
and they were murdered that should
enrage all of us
not just hispanics but all of us so how
do we solve the problem of racism
i mean that's a 64 thousand dollar
question you can't solve something
unless you talk about it intelligently
and i invite every single hispanic
every single las vegan to come out to
see this film to start
a dialogue about racism and how we can
minimize it
if you ask me i think it all starts at
home with kids and how their parents
talk to them
i mean your first relationship is
critical that's kind of sets the tone i
think for the rest of your life
i don't know how parents these days are
talking to their kids
if the parents are racist well then the
kids could be racist
so i think it all starts at home it all
starts
during those dinner time conversations
during those bedroom conversations
what exactly is being talked about
inside people's homes these days
i think that's where it all starts
obviously education
uh studying other people's cultures i
think is a very fascinating thing
but uh unfortunately today there just
seems to be a lot of uh
separation and divide what you have to
be careful is uh
about is if it's personal you know you
want to stay objective
because it's so easy to personalize it
to the point where
okay now you're losing a little bit of
the focus of the film so
i dove into this thing with so much
passion because it happened in a city
that has become my adopted home
el paso is a very welcoming warm
beautiful community
half a million people it sits right on
the border of mexico
you'll never find more welcoming people
in my opinion and i've lived everywhere
and you know i know this city went
through hell with the route 91 mass
shooting almost 500 people were shot
unfortunately now el paso has their own
mulligan too
el paso has their own scar just like las
vegas
people here will never forget about
route 91 and people in el paso now will
never forget about the walmart incident
so um i think in the walmart case it's
so important to talk about racism
i mean the way the media reported this
particular tragedy in el paso they kind
of lumped it together with all the other
mass shootings
and they really never talked about the
hate aspect and that's what this was all
about
three out of the top 10 mass shootings
in american history deal with hispanics
being targeted
i would say maybe one percent of the
people in our country know that
and that one percent might be the family
members of the people that were killed
i mean for someone to go 10 hours out of
their way to
carry out their evil plan what does that
tell you i mean that's
that's hatred to the point of
desperation you know people
mention it well he could have done it
where he lived he could have done it in
another city he chose el paso
el paso being a border town 83 hispanic
so uh the killer knew exactly what he
was doing now he's going to be facing
a trial soon i don't know when that's
going to be exactly
but he does have an upcoming trial and
his lawyers right now are trying to do
everything in their power to keep him
alive and
claim insanity if you're insane
um then you're not going to do what you
did in terms of
carrying out a plan that's what i mean
yes the act itself was insane but
the way he carried out the plan
carefully driving to el paso it's not
like he got lost he went to el paso he
knew what he was doing
shot a bunch of mexican people turned
himself in
and admitted to what he did i mean
that to me is someone who knew what he
was doing
so to claim insanity to me is totally
off
what really impressed me about las vegas
is when i was public speaking at unlv
i was told that the most diverse campus
in the country is unlv
and when i went into a classroom i felt
i was at the united nations
i said this is awesome this is cool this
is cultural diversity at its best
you can't be a bigot at unlv you just
can't because
you're going to be the minority you
shouldn't be a bigot no matter what
but uh at unlv you almost feel like
you're walking
um in manhattan it's so diverse and i
loved it i think the film would resonate
here because racism
affects any race the word racism comes
from the word race
and this is one of the most diverse if
not the most diverse city
in the country and we have all walks of
life here yeah it helps to be a tourist
town
but uh it's awesome walking the strip
and seeing all the different
uh cultures and countries and faces and
i think las vegas may take it for
granted that they're in a city where so
many people love to visit
so many people come here and and decide
to live here and start a family start a
career
and that's one of the things that
impresses me most about las vegas is
it's cultural diversity
unfortunately i think we're trending in
the wrong direction we're seeing so many
deaths now through shootings just just
violent deaths where
families are being devastated lives are
being altered cities and communities are
being
greatly affected by this uh don't forget
pray for shea
the policeman i can't get that one out
of my head the other day i was taking an
uber i was going right through
circus circus near the travel lodge and
i thought about shea
i said that could happen to anybody that
could happen to my driver right now that
could happen to me
i mean we live in a society now where it
seems like everything's up for grabs
all the mass shootings all the violent
things that are going on especially in
las vegas
this city is turning ugly quickly and
you can blame the virus all you want
people are depressed people are losing
their money left and right but
i've always said a setback sets up a
comeback i mean we're all in this
together i mean this virus has affected
all of us and we something we never
asked for something that we didn't
create
it came from somewhere else and when
something like that happens we all have
to
realize that and say you know we all
have to come together here we're all in
this together
we're all being affected in some way
some more than others
and when that happens it's never been
more important to unite and come
together
unfortunately we're seeing more
separation i think
and violence and people shooting at each
other and
just really depressed whether it's
financially
people are down emotionally we have no
idea where this is turning this virus
and i think it's leading to more crime
and uh people are losing their
businesses
people are losing their homes uh their
jobs
um people are not getting the proper
unemployment probably
so uh where do we go from here i mean
that's a great question
and unfortunately vegas has seen their
share of violence especially lately
that one guy that was arrested from the
whole henderson incident i mean
just reading that that was beyond
troubling
i would say the greatest myth about the
el paso walmart tragedy is that
police were heroes when they certainly
were not
they got there in six minutes and they
missed the killer because of that they
could not secure the scene
so we have wounded bodies laying there
bleeding out it only takes a few minutes
to bleed out
so a lot of the bodies were left on the
ground for 20 to 30 minutes
so that's a problem so all that stemmed
from the fact that police missed the
killer
the killer drove away he could have
actually driven back to dallas
he turned himself in he surrendered and
while surrendering he could have taken
out one of the one or two of the
officers
as well so there's a lot of things in
the movie that
when people come out of it they always
tell me i didn't know that i didn't know
that part i didn't know that
it's amazing what people don't know
about this tragedy even el pasoans
i call it the unknown tragedy to a large
degree
the way i delved into this thing was was
just so much
passion and care because i love el paso
and i really needed to get to the bottom
of it i remember when i first heard
about it i said to myself how in the
world does a killer
walk towards a walmart shoot people
outside then inside
shoot more people as he's leaving get
into his car and drive away how does a
killer do that and get away
how does he commit the seventh largest
mass shooting in u.s history
and drive away it just did not make any
sense to me so i had to dive into this
thing
so you're going to hear from really
really important people in this
documentary people that were shot
people that were direct witnesses family
members
good samaritans this is a clean
sweep of what happened august 3rd 2019
in el paso
el paso's worst day a few years ago i
made a documentary about the
route 91 mass shooting here in las vegas
it's now on amazon prime
called one october unfortunately this
city has a huge scar behind it
and they know what a mass shooting is
unfortunately here's one way for las
vegas to look and see
how another community felt and reacted
from a mass shooting
obviously the one in el paso is on a
much smaller scale
even though it's a lot but um
you know a lot of people share las vegas
as pain
because mass shootings seem to be such a
consistent thing now
one thing i do in my film which i think
is
noteworthy is that i don't mention the
killer's name
because i think that creates copycats
and i said earlier about documentaries
um they're meant to inform educate raise
awareness for change
so i'm trying to raise awareness to
other media outlets stop mentioning the
killer's name because
um if you omit their name altogether
well then maybe that will prevent
future mass shootings because now
killers will know going in their name
will never be mentioned again
so i think it's worth a try i mean what
else has worked
uh as i said uh i think we're trending
in the wrong direction in terms of gun
violence
um i'm not gonna get political here i
just want to keep it on a human level
bottom line is this we have too many
innocent people being murdered
by gunfire period
especially here in las vegas the stories
i hear coming out of this city is just
so heartbreaking
pray for shea i mean i i i literally
think of shea every day
i don't know the man but what he went
through
no family should go through that and
just to hear that he's
paralyzed from the neck down has to
breathe out of a ventilator for the rest
of his life
i mean when you read stories like that
you got to be thankful that
you wake up healthy every day and when
you start complaining about your
problems and you look at shea
you have to ask yourself what really is
a problem i brought the film to las
vegas because vegas has a large
hispanic population about one-third
and a lot of them are mexican and this
was the ultimate hate crime towards
mexican people
i invite every hispanic i encourage
every las vegas
to come out to watch this film to start
an intense dialogue about racism
why are hispanics being targeted why is
racism
still existing to this day like there's
no tomorrow
why is there so much separation and
divide why is this a conversation that
people do not want to have
we need to attack these issues that are
so
serious and hurtful that's causing
people to get murdered